what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
what's going on guys this is Rob and I
wanted to talk to talk about the Living
Tribunal and Avengers 4 um this is gonna
be one of those videos where I have a
theory but in the process of getting to
the theory I'm gonna dump a ton of
information on you guys so you guys are
gonna walk away no one a whole lot more
about Marvel than you probably did
before unless you guys are mridu Marvel
for a long time and you'll probably know
about the same that you had that you had
before we started but for the non comic
book reader you're gonna learn all kinds
of crazy stuff so first things first
what is the Living Tribunal and what
purpose does it serve okay but loving
Tribunal is basically this judge of the
multiverse it's this being that exists
out there in in Marvel Comics and
there's only one of it it might appear
in multiple universes at the same time
but there's only one of it all those
different versions are just false you
know small fact similes of itself when
it comes to the tribunal its job is to
look at a universe and to say okay this
universe cannot violate the mystical
balance they can't have too much power
can have more power than the other
universes it has to maintain the cosmic
order of things now what does that mean
because that's a very ambiguous
statement so what does that mean okay so
back in the 1960s really back in 1967 I
think it was exactly the year that it
came out but it was strange tales 157
and 158 I'm pretty sure was a two-part
story that dealt with the villains zom
back then in 1960s when it came to the
Doctor Strange comics there were really
no rules Martin you know magic was a
pretty new thing for Marvel comics for
the most part back then like Doctor
Strange was about as powerful as you got
I mean for the most part like you had
things like Galactus but the the origin
of Galactus himself and like the full
might and power he actually possessed
that wasn't explained until 1969 with
Thor issue number 169 so for the most
part even Galactus himself was ambiguous
in terms of all the power that he had in
his disposal now in modern days there's
a far more organized and a much better
ranking system in terms of how powerful
different characters are Marvel over the
years has released something called
files they're basically one-shots and
it's a way to basically say like Santos
is a universal threat if the
annihilation if the annihilation Nova
core files are to be believed that like
you know the these this character is
this power
this character is that powerful so on
and so forth they don't really rank them
in relation to each other but still you
know you have a far more organized
system now than you did back then but
back in the 1960s it was just kind of
whatever and dr. strange was just a guy
who would like jump from dimension to
dimension and because he gained his
spells from mysticism
there was really no limit to what he
could do Marvel could just have him do
something and say well there's his spell
that's how he's able to do it from there
it began to sort of get into the realm
of like expanding images wild and kooky
things and that's why if you go back and
you read strange tales number 158 you
see the first appear I'm sorry 138
rather you see the first appearance of
like eternity the representation of the
universe itself of the actual space it
occupies there's stories where you see
infinity who's the representation of
time how much time passes between the
time the universe first exists and the
time it ends you see entities like
oblivion which is the representation of
the time between when the universe is
destroyed and when a new universe is
made you see like all these different
crazy entities out there before the
tribunal because of the fact that it was
originally a Doctor Strange character it
was really just kind of isolated to
mysticism simply saying I exist to
maintain the cosmic order when it comes
to balance in the universe basically
meaning there cannot be an imbalance of
magical energies and the reason why was
because at the time there was a villain
called Zhong and zom was just this crazy
powerful guy and he still is I would say
Dom I'm sorry not Dom Dominic Toretto I
would say zom is is wildly more powerful
than like Dormammu and Doctor Strange
and the ancient one I mean it took the
Living Tribunal to stop zom if that
gives you any indication of how powerful
he is it's it's insane it's one of those
things were like if zom full-on invaded
the main marvel universe at full power
no one would be able to stop them like
it would like unless it let me Tribunal
or somebody stepped in no one will be
able to defeat him I mean he's just that
powerful
I mean how that I mean inevitably
somebody's gonna ask well what about
somber PSA's the Infinity Gauntlet no
clue Marvell never answers that question
so because of that you get into like
this really cool situation where the
Living Tribunal is just there and it's
very regimented and very structured the
problem with this is that because of the
fact that Stan Lee and Jack Kirby's line
of storytelling in the 60s and 70s was
really light-hearted and it didn't
really focus on like insanely godlike
powerful characters once they basically
stepped down
and then you had other riders who began
to step in then you started seeing like
insane levels of power in comics powers
that was you know powers that were so
extreme that while they weren't based on
like magic and mysticism they rival the
powers of dr. strange and in a lot of
instances actually exceeded his own
power
this became even more of an issue when
it turned into dr. strange who was
summoned by the vishanti which is one of
the people were like we're a brunt of
his spells come from he was summoned by
the Musante and then he refused to fight
on their behalf they took his power away
they made a new sorcerer of supreme and
then he got his powers back but there
were half of what they were so he was
basically weaker after the after that
whole you know primordial like primal
gods civil war whatever it was but the
fact remains here with the tribunal
because he was based strictly in
mysticism as more and more powerful
beings began to enter into the Marvel
landscape from different writers the
questions sort of began to take form
well what would the Living Tribunal do
about them now it wasn't like anybody
sat down right at least as far as I'm
aware it wasn't like somebody sat down
and said okay guys we have these really
powerful mutants and we have like some
really powerful villains like molecule
man what's the tribunal gonna do here it
just sort of gravitated and just kind of
turn into an answer to that question
here's a really good example in 1981
really before 1981 probably going back
as far as AI mid 1970s Marvel was
branching out of the United States and
Marvel was looking to start publishing
comics in the United Kingdom so they
launched Marvel UK and of course they
gave them their own captain britain that
kind of a thing
but in that line of stories you saw a
villain arise by the name of Mad Jim
Jasper's we talked about him before I've
got videos on him but for the new folks
he is really powerful but he was so
powerful they had to wipe out his
universe and the reason why was because
of the fact that in Marvel Comics he is
a really obscure group you never really
hear about it but a Marvel Comics you
have something called the Omni versatile
development court and again this was one
of those different multiversal aspects
that existed that kind of tried to
answer the question of why the Living
Tribunal doesn't step into like every
situation when any being that's not
magical has an insane amount of power
and so the Omni versatile development
court serves one purpose and that's to
monitor all the universes across the
multiverse and make sure that their
evolution all happens at around the same
time basically meaning that like every
universe has superheroes every universe
has supervillains every universe has
super-powered beings and every universe
has super-powered
the whole nine yards I guess designed to
make sure all that stuff works what had
happened is in an alternate reality that
had a numerical designation called Earth
238 that Jim Jasper's was a guy who had
the ability to warp reality on a
universal scale but he didn't really
want to like control the universe he
just wanted to be the only superhero the
only super-powered being on earth and so
what he did is he created a being called
the fury and the fury had the power to
adapt to everyone's powers it didn't
matter what those powers were if they
used it the fury could adapt to it and
then overcome those powers and kill them
so think of the fury as like this it
knows from Days of Future past just not
nearly as a week and so because of that
wounded up happening is the theory
traveled across the planet of the planet
Earth at the behest imagine Jasper's and
killed off every single superhero that
it found and so the result was that in
this universe there were no superheroes
there was no super-powered beings except
for Jim Jasper's the Omni versatile
development court saw this and it didn't
know what Jim Jasper's had done all it
knew was that earth didn't have any
superpower beings except for one and so
what they did is they initiated
something called the push they said
we're gonna jumpstart the evolutionary
process of humanity here and we're gonna
start giving rise to beings with
superpowers
Jim Jasper's realized what was going on
and basically initiated something called
the Jasper's warp and what this did is
it started emanating all throughout the
universe like it was it was it was crazy
it started in a localized space and he
was like twisting buildings inside out
and like like people were just being all
all twisted and mangled up and it
started emanating from from the the
local region into like this like
affecting the whole earth to affecting
the whole solar system moving on to the
universe and so on and so forth and when
the omniversal development court
realized what they'd done they came to
the to the real only logical conclusion
that this Jasper's warp is going to
expand into the multiverse and like
distort and work the entire multiverse
and so they did the only thing they
could do which was destroy the entire
universe of Jim Jasper's now anybody who
looks at that story will say well why
wasn't the Living Tribunal involved
because at the time the Living Tribunal
didn't really respond to non magical
threats because it just hadn't been
written that way it really wasn't in
charter that didn't really happen on on
any real measure of a scale I would say
until a couple of things took place the
first was a story involving protégé and
never remember for the life I want to
see it's the guardians of the galaxy
3000 story and I could never remember
when that came out I want to say it was
in like the late 80s or sometime during
the 80s maybe in the 90s and then of
course the Infinity Gauntlet story in in
in 91 and what this did is it removed
the Living Tribunal from strictly being
a magical based protector or judge or
what have you I think the the Infinity
Gauntlet is probably I mean it's
obviously the most popular one that
dealt with that since I imagine a lot of
you have never heard of Protege who was
a crazy powerful kid um kind of a kind
of it you know kind of getting him in
this for a second the protege was a kid
who was created to be the leader of the
universal Church of truth in a different
universe and what what was going on was
that protege had the power to duplicate
the powers of anyone he saw with no
upper limit and eventually like he was
copying the powers of like local people
and then he was copying the powers of
cosmic entities and then eventually
copied the power of the Living Tribunal
and so letting Tribunal judged against
him I'm sorry uh it was scathing escape
from the judge whichever one it was one
of the the II one of the Celestials
stayed in the approver judged against
protege and the Living Tribunal absorbed
him and then that was the end of him but
when it came to like Infinity Gauntlet I
would say that's really like the big
landmark story with a Living Tribunal
moved away from just being magic and
dealing with with various threats and
the idea at the time and I'm sure a lot
people know about this but for those of
guys who don't the idea at the time of
course of Thanos gaining the Infinity
Gauntlet the force is really the good
guys essentially like when to let me
tribunal alongside the cosmic entities
and said we need you to judge on this
like we have a guy here who's gaining
absolute power and the response of the
Living Tribunal was I judge in favor of
Thanos because he didn't make the
Infinity stones so it's not like they're
an artificial means to attain power like
they were they're born as part of the
universe and so he's literally just
harnessing in a part of the universe
itself he's not violating any laws here
he's not using magic so he has an upset
the mystical balance at all and he's
following the natural order of things in
the sense that Thanos sought to replace
eternity the representation of the
universe instead of rule alongside of it
and so because of that the Living
Tribunal decreed the natural order of
things is that the weak are removed to
make way for the strong that's just the
way it is this way it always will be is
just the natural order of things and so
ultimately the Living Tribunal said I
judge anything
favor of Thanos and bailed and left and
that was it the Infinity Gauntlet event
transpired it reached his conclusion
Adam warlock got the gauntlet and then
he was put on trial and the living crowd
at tribunal said I judge against Adam
warlock and the reason why was because
Adam warlock looked to rule alongside
eternity as opposed to replacing
eternity and that upset the balance of
things it was a being with too much
power that wouldn't have like a check
and balance there'd be nobody there in
order to like to for him to basically
take their place in the sense that he's
because eternity is gonna exist and
because Adam warlock is gonna exist
you're basically gonna have two of the
exact cosmic entity in a universe and
that violates the natural order of
things and so the result was that Adam
warlock was forced to disperse the gems
they wouldn't work in unison anymore and
that was it and so going forward into
Marvel Comics for the most part that's
just kind of what happened with the
tribunal he started out as magic he was
eventually expanded small little stories
here and there it was just writers
invoking the tribunal in their story to
serve a particular purpose and that was
really about it I mean it was kind of a
cool situation because when you sat down
and you looked at the way things were in
the sixties sure dr. strange being a
powerful Galactus being powerful things
like that but the cosmic entities are
part and parcel there to the universe
itself for all the purpose they serve
they're like stars and planets and solar
systems they're just a part of the
universe so they need to be there they
have to exist they don't upset the
cosmic balance of things but then
somebody rising up with just an insane
level of power if for example like
Franklin Richards sought to sought to
basically do exactly what Galactus does
a say for example that Galactus you know
with him traveling around the universe
consuming planets so on and so forth if
Franklin Richards said well I'm gonna do
that exact same thing but let me
tribunal would step in and say nope
there can only be one person that plays
the role of Galactus and that's Galactus
like nobody else can do what he does and
so Franklin Richards would probably be
like destroyed or forced to go back to
the way that he was before or something
along those lines but again it's just
riders changing things up that's the
funny thing about comics nothing's ever
an absolute you can't take a level of
power here and then a level of power
there and compare them because they
change all the time and so with that in
mind like that's that's kind of where
the tribunal stands at the moment that's
the role that it basically serves now
getting into Avengers 4 in truth it's a
funny thing about the Living Tribunal
because the only real evidence people
have for the possibility that it may or
may not exist is from Doctor Strange
when they referenced
staff of the Living Tribunal and it's
cool when you get into that because in
Marvel Comics The Living Tribunal has
the solar staff so it actually has that
kind of a weapon in the comics itself
but we don't really know how that
translates to the movies in truth it
could just be that it's just called the
staff of the Living Tribunal because
maybe in the order of the ancients the
the group that dr. strange belongs to
you that there is simply just like a
group of people like three people who
essentially just like governed that
whole thing and they're the Living
Tribunal and so that's why it's called
the staff of the Living Tribunal or it
could be the Living Tribunal actually
exists in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
we know the multiverse is there and the
the ancient one established in the
Doctor Strange movie that there are laws
to each one particular universe
governing magical magical energy and it
wouldn't really make any sense to have
laws if there was no one there to
enforce them and so because of them
it makes sense that we you know the
Living Tribunal would actually exist the
question is if the Living Tribunal
showed up in Avengers 4 what could we
expect in all honesty I wouldn't expect
anything I would expect the Living
Tribunal to be there for like five
minutes and they would say hey like how
do you judge on this and the living
tribunals like I judge in favor of
tano's the natural order of things and
then it would just leave that would be
it because it is a huge amount of power
but still like Thanos is doing what he
believes to be the right thing and it's
using the very fundamental forces of the
universe itself they're not artificial
creations and so there would be no real
violation in there but on the other hand
the Living Tribunal could say well
Thanos is wiping out half a life in the
universe that's not okay but it depends
on how they want to adapt like the
comics to the movies and and how far
they want to go the other half of this
is that the the reason why I don't
really see the Living Tribunal acting is
because if it did then it would only
ever really go one way it would just in
the Infinity goal that would be it it
would just say the gyms don't work
anymore done and that would be the end
of that that movie would be 30 minutes
long it would be nothing more than that
um either that or they would be bold in
saying that like the Infinity Gauntlet
rivals or is more powerful than the
living tribe you know which you know I'd
have a hard time getting on getting on
board with that I wouldn't follow that
belief the judge of the multiverse is
weaker than an Infinity Gauntlet like
that that wouldn't really make any sense
to me but still it is kind of cool when
you get into that whole thing because it
could go any direction I mean
it looks to be weaker in the movies than
it is in the comics I mean half those
flight to the movies would have lasted
like that they would have been over so
fast because of how powerful the
gauntlet is I mean there's no glitz and
glamour to it you just say a thing or
you think a thing and the gauntlet does
it you know it just makes it happen and
then again of course even Thanos himself
as a little bit weaker so maybe letting
tribunals weaker I'm not I'm not sure if
it even exists at all but just kind of a
theory you know just sort of throwing
this out there just just kind of getting
my my thoughts out there in the realm of
cosmic powers and so on and so forth let
me know what you guys think because I'm
kind of curious I know the Living
Tribunal is one of these characters
that's ambiguous to a lot of people and
they're curious about it but they don't
really know how it works I'm sorry what
are the other things I want to mention
here to you is how the Living Tribunal
judges just kind of a quick thing before
we end this The Living Tribunal has
three phases and whenever the Living
Tribunal makes a judgement call
all three phases have to agree if one of
the three phases does not agree then
like then there's just further
deliberation they have to continue
presenting their case until all three
phases agree so it's it's kind of cool
in terms of how that works but when the
three phases do agree then the judgment
is handed down and that's that's the way
this so uh yeah I just kind of figured I
throw that in there for those of you
guys who were kind of curious no one
knows what the fourth face of the Living
Tribunal is some say strangers some say
it's you know a reflection of whoever's
looking at it you know it's it gets kind
of weird but anyway guys we're gonna win
and bring this video to an end and if
you were new here to comment explain
make sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the Rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]